Now let's talk about how to implement any of these, see if there's any difficulties,
an areas that we think might be hard to implement.
The board can be some kind of two-dimensional array, maybe a list of lists is one possibility.
One thing I'm not quite clear on now is do I need one board or two?
It's clear I need one board to hold all the letters, but then there's also the bonus squares.
Should that be part of the same board or should that be a separate board
and the letters are layered on top of this background of bonus squares?
I'm not quite sure yet, but I'm not too worried about it,
because I can make either approach work.
A letter can be one character string.
A word can be a string.
A hand can also be a string. It could also be a list of letters. Either one would be fine.
Any collection of letters would be okay.
Note that a set would not work for the hand.
The hand can't be a set of letters, because we might have duplicates,
and sets don't allow duplicates.
Now, for the notion of a legal play, we'll have some function that generates legal plays,
given a board position and a hand, and then the plays themselves will need some representation.
Maybe they can be something like a tuple of say starting position--
for example, "RITZY" starts in this location, the direction in which they're going--
are they going across or down, the two allow about directions--and the word itself.
In this case, RITZY. That seems like a good representation for a legal play.
I'm not quite sure yet what the representation of a position or a direction should be,
but that's easy enough.
A score--we'll have some function to compute the score.
For letters, we can have a dictionary that says the value of Z is 10.
For plays we'll need some function to compute that.
For the bonus squares, we'll need some mapping from a position on the board
to double word or triple letter or whatever.
A dictionary is a set of words.
The blank letter--well, we said letters were strings, so that's probably okay.
We could use the string space or the string underscore, to represent the blank.
Then it's dealing with it that will be an issue later on.
Now, I'm a little bit worried about blanks, because in poker Jokers were easy.
We just said, replace them by any card and just deal with all the possibilities.
Our routines are fast enough that we could probably deal with them all.
Here I'm pretty confident we can make it fast enough that that approach will work,
but it doesn't quite work because not only do we have to try all possibilities for the letter,
but the scoring rules are actually different.
When you use a blank instead of a letter, you don't get the letter scores for that blank.
We'll have to have scoring know about blanks and not just know about filling things in.
That'll be a complication.
But overall I went through all the concepts.
I've got an implementation for both.
Some of them are functions that I don't quite know how to do,
but I don't see anything that looks like a show stopper.
I think I can go ahead.
The difficulty then is not that I have to invent something new
in order to solve one of the problems.
The difficulty is just that there's so much.
When faced with a problem of this size or problems can be much larger,
the notion of pacing is an important one.
What do I mean by that?
It means I want to attack this, and I know I'm not going to solve it all at once.
I'm not just going to sit down for 20 minutes and knock out the whole problem.
It's going to be a lot longer than that.
I want to have pacing in that I have intermediate goals along the way
where I can say, okay, now I'm going focus on one part of the problem,
and I'm going to get that done.
Then when I'm done with that part, then I can move on to the next part.
If you don't have that pacing, you can lose your focus.
You can get discouraged that there's so much left to do.
But if you break it up into bite-sized pieces, then you can say, okay, I'm almost there.
I just have to finish a little bit more, and now this piece will be done,
and then I can move on to the next piece.
The first piece I'm going to look at is finding words from a hand.
In other words, I'm going ignore the whole board.
I'm going to say pretend the board isn't there and pretend all we have is the hand,
and we have the dictionary, a set of legal words.
I want to know out of that hand, what words in the dictionary can I make?